tonight we bring you text messages you
were never supposed to see suggesting to
FBI employees may have tried to use a
personal relationship with a federal
judge a FISA judge to influence the
investigation into the Trump
presidential campaign this comes on a
day when a career FBI executive could
lose his full government pension after
being accused of acting on a similar
bias against the president chief
intelligence correspondent Catherine
Herridge is here with details good even
Catherine well thank you Brett in late
July 2016 after the Clinton email case
closed and the FBI opened its Russia
investigation text messages indicate FBI
agent Peter struck an FBI lawyer Lisa
Paige talked about exploiting Struck's
friendship with a federal judge who had
later handled the prosecution of former
national security adviser Mike Flynn
investigators working for House
Republicans Jim Jordan and Mark meadows
reviewed the original John documents at
the Justice Department and took notes
because the copy sent to Congress were
heavily redacted with key details
blacked out texting on their work phones
the to FBI lover suggests setting up a
cocktail party with Federal Judge
Rudolph Contreras who also sits on the
secret FISA Surveillance Court on July
25th 2016 Paige writes judge Contreras
is on the Fiske did you know that just
appointed two months ago struck I did we
talked about it before and after I need
to get together with him Paige continues
I can't imagine either one of you could
talk about anything in detail meaningful
enough to warrant recusal struck really
Rudy I'm in charge of espionage for the
FBI any espionage FISA warrants comes
before him which did he do given his
friend oversees them after texting about
an unrelated issue struck rights
Contreras super thoughtful and rigorous
about ethics and conflicts and suggested
a social setting with others would
probably be better than a one-on-one
meeting I'm sorry I'm just gonna have to
invite you to that cocktail party of
course you'll have to be there have to
come up with some other work people
cover for action Paige why more six is a
perfectly fine dinner party it's not
clear from the text messages whether the
cocktail party ever happened and the
federal judge attended after national
security advisor Mike Flynn pled guilty
to lying to the FBI in December less
than a week later Contreras was removed
from the case without explanation
congressional investigators questioned
whether there is a connection to struck
who also conducted Flint's FBI interview
the newly public text messages seem to
further undercut the FBI leadership's
longstanding claims that the bureau is
above politics has the dismissal of mr.
Comey in any way impeded interrupted
stopped or negatively impacted any of
the work any investigation or anything
ongoing projects at the Federal Bureau
of Investigations there has been no
effort to impede our investigation to
date quite simply put sir you cannot
stop the men and women of the FBI from
doing the right thing protecting the
American people and upholding the
Constitution decision from the Attorney
General Jeff sessions on the fate of the
former FBI deputy director Andrew McCabe
you just saw there and whether he will
be fired for cause impacting his pension
is expected at any time Brett it's
Friday afternoon we will watch for any
releases Catherine thank you you're
welcome